Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number, which is
two one nine two. David P. Here is a voicemail
from the man we know is the most chaotic
caller of all time, Billy Harrison. And
this caller is a great example of why the United
States isn't a better country. OK, let's listen.
Speaker 8: David Pakman Billy
Harrison here calling again.
I'm calling on the fact that you here. I'm
watching a lot of video that you have with Trump,
as I've watched a lot of video already, but I kind
of go back and watch and laugh at it, really. Me
and my wife called a while back, I'm gonna ask you
to man, you debate loud, but you refused to do it.
Speaker 1: As I've said before, Billy, you
can call in when we take live calls. I mean,
I'm not going to debate live. I'm going to fly to
wherever you live and debate you in person if you
call in any time and confront me about whatever.
Speaker 8: But you're claiming about the lab
in Ukraine that someone has to prove
it, that there's no evidence of it.
Speaker 1: No, see, we talked about this earlier.
I'm not claiming anyone has to prove that there is
no evidence of it. What I'm explaining is that no
one has brought forth any evidence that the labs
in Ukraine are in any way unique or pernicious
relative to all the other labs that do pathogen
research all over Europe and all over the
world. And it certainly is no justification
for the Russian invasion. That's the issue.
Speaker 8: Somebody in and called you out on that
about Tucker Carlson saying that it
that it you know, that it was true and
I was reporting on it. And you said that it is
stupid for someone to basically say, you know,
start saying stuff like that without no evidence.
Speaker 1: Is anybody else even following this,
Speaker 8: but you don't have
no evidence that an intruder?
Speaker 1: And of course, this gets
us to the exact Russell's teapot
principle that I mentioned earlier people who
don't have any understanding of what we what the
burden of proof mechanism is. And my I'm not going
to go point counterpoint with Billy Harrison.
But what I do want to mention is if someone
so misunderstands what is even being said,
how do we even talk to these people? They don't
even it's not that we disagree about our analysis.
The guy doesn't even have any idea what's
been said, he's wrong about what Tucker said,
he's wrong about what I said, how there's
no shared basis of fact. It's a very sad
situation in this country. Very, very sad.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Sign up at Join Packman dot com to get access
Speaker 2: to the bonus show where you want to
make money and everybody else that makes money
to fund themselves is bad. We will see you then.